you understand why guys would have a
problem with the one with a high body
count do you understand the logic behind
us I think it's insecurity that's where
it comes from it's like do they really
want to have a woman that is just a
virgin because she's not gonna be good
and she's gonna have no experience they
don't need you to be good though that's
so boring isn't that it's boring that's
so boring that's so like just that just
sounds transactional to me you know
what's so funny about this topic about
sex and women it's so funny because as a
man I seem to have more knowledge about
female anatomy than most women there's
one thing I know growing up with around
women having sisters is that the woman's
anatomy is so delicate that she could
get infection simply from just sitting
on the toilet simply from sitting in the
wrong place maybe even using her
underwear more than once like just the
little things so imagine 10 different
books that's crazy